all right this is from uh the daily wire
says elon musk is weighing in on the new
amazon series the lord of the rings the
rings of power and it sounds like the
billionaire tesla ceo is not a fan
tolkien is turning in his grave musk
tweeted monday in response to the series
which just released episodes uh on uh
two episodes last thursday almost every
male character so far is a coward a jerk
or both
only galadriel is i guess that's a lord
of the rings character is brave smart
and nice
now this is part of a overall kind of
backlash against i guess against the
lord of the rings series daily wire has
also has this report there's been a lot
of hype leading up to amazon's lord of
the rings adaptation the rings of power
but now some fans are saying it's a huge
flop the series premiered the first two
episodes
thursday currently has an 84 critic
rating and a 36 audience rating on
rotten tomatoes this certainly isn't the
first time critics and viewers disagreed
on whether a show was a triumph or a
fail
but some reviewers are accusing fans of
being racist for their one star reviews
of course we knew that was going to
happen a writer for the hollywood
reporter likened these reviewers to
miserable little trolls who were
review-bombing the series simply because
casting directors chose to add black
actors into it
so this is this is the narrative now
that we're getting from the media i
haven't watched this show i have no
interest in watching it and i'm a fan of
lord of the rings actually but it's
because i'm a fan of lord of the rings
that i'm not going to watch amazon's
version of it and i and i
i said this from the very beginning the
first time they announced the series i
was warning everyone it's going to be a
disappointment it is going to disappoint
you because hollywood in the year 2022
does not have the
ability i mean it would it would be
in any era it would be very difficult
to make a lord of the rings series which
yes maybe it's based on some of
tolkien's work
but
you're basically telling your own story
and now we're going to stack it up
against one of the classic fantasy
novels of all time fantasy series of all
time
so in any era of hollywood
um that's a lot to ask
i mean you're almost doomed to fail
already
but especially in this era
it's just it's impossible
that the series can be good
uh they don't have the capacity to tell
these kinds of stories anymore and when
i say capacity i don't mean from a
financial perspective they got all the
money in the world it's been a billion
dollars
on this series
uh which
by the way you don't hear a lot of
complaints from from the left about that
you know they say about like elon musk
when he made an offer for twitter they
said well why don't you you could have
taken that money and solved world hunger
well amazon spent a billion dollars on a
on a tv show
how much world how much of world hunger
could they have solved with that
but they've got the money but they don't
have there's not the there's not the
the spiritual capacity to tell stories
like this anymore in hollywood
but the narrative is that uh the people
don't like the show because there are
some black actors in it
and of course because you know
the people that are watching lord of the
rings it's the first time they've seen a
black actor in the show and they're all
racist and so that's why they have a
problem with it
then you you go and you read the
audience reviews and what you see not
surprisingly is that almost all of them
don't like the show because they think
it's boring they don't like how it's
written and all of those things
i looked at some of the reviews i didn't
see one person complaining about the
fact that there's a black actor
now with that said
audiences at this point have a very low
tolerance for anything that even smells
woke
like the minute there's a hint of
wokeness
and of course just having a black actor
doesn't mean that you're trying to do
something woke
but the minute there's a hint of it like
if there's a hint
that they put a character in the show
just for for no re not because it
advances a story but just for diversity
concerns
the minute there's even a hint of that
audiences are repelled and for good
reason because we're sick
so i don't think that's the primary
complaint here well before you go uh hit
the subscribe button and ring the bell
and while you're at it if you want to go
watch or listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated